If you're planning on giving a
Toastmasters evaluation, this video is a
must-watch.
In just a few seconds, you're going to
see the same speech I recently saw at my
local Kelowna Toastmasters Club here in
Kelowna, BC, Canada. And then you're
going to see my evaluation of that
speech. And you're going to want to
watch this full video because at the
very end, I am going to show you the
specific note breakdown I did in order
to create that evaluation.
So, you're learning three times. First
off, you're learning from one of my
club's award-winning Toastmasters. Her
name is Samantha Hildebrand. She
recently did very well with the Tall
Tales Toastmasters contest. And she is
giving a speech on overcoming some of
the nerves and anxiety that you might
experience
before public speaking. So, you're going
to learn from that. And then you're
going to see my evaluation of the
speech. Hopefully, you learn from that.
And then at the end, you're definitely
going to learn when we break down the
process. So, to start it off, here is
Samantha's speech titled Speaking
Anyway.
>> I want you to think of a moment
where you felt anxious.
Could be a job interview,
an uncomfortable conversation,
or maybe it's your name being called to
stand at the front of the room and give
a presentation.
Today, I'm going to share some tools
that I've picked up
over the last couple years that have
helped ease my nerves. Good morning,
Toastmasters here and our most welcome
guests on Zoom.
Being nervous before a speech, normal.
Doesn't matter if you're beginner or
experienced.
But it's how you handle those nerves.
Do you let the nerves
overtake you and shut down?
Or do you have the tenacity
to
>> [clears throat]
>> shut the nerves down and overcome them?
Well, let's start with
what triggers
anxiety.
It can be a new
uncomfortable situation,
the risk of failing,
maybe looking like a fool standing in
the front of the room,
or having a bored audience.
When I first joined Toastmasters,
my name got called for a table topics,
and I had to come up here. I don't
understand how I made it up here because
my knees were so weak.
My hands were shaking. They still do
sometimes.
My heart
pounding like it's going to come out of
my chest.
And I know I would start talking really,
really fast.
I wouldn't know if I hit the green light
or not until I was sitting down and I
heard my evaluation.
Most of the time it was
"You need to slow down, then maybe
you'll get that green light. Challenge
yourself. Hit a minute." Okay, okay.
And the other gift that I think we've
all heard at some point in our life,
"Just relax."
Yeah, relax.
How?
>> [clears throat]
>> Practice.
You need to practice. That is the most
important thing.
A few months ago when I was at the
semifinals for the tall tales contest,
I was standing on the sideline
trying to rehearse my speech in my head
waiting to be called up. I couldn't even
remember the second line of my speech.
All of a sudden I hear, "Samantha
Hildebrand!"
I walked up there
looking as confident as I could, not
knowing how this is going to happen,
because I have no idea what's next on my
speech.
But, then it just flowed.
And that's because of the practice.
My husband and my kids heard my speech
over a hundred times, I'm sure of it. My
friends heard it, Toastmasters clubs. If
you get in front of people and you
practice, it helps ease those nerves.
And then you need to visualize.
What is it that you want?
Picture this.
You get up from your chair, you walk
confidently up to the front of the room.
You take a breath.
>> [sighs]
>> You deliver your speech clear. You hit
every objective.
Open body language. You even use the
word of the day.
You look around at the end of your
speech.
>> [applause]
>> Everybody's clapping for you.
You stand here
taking it in,
feeling confident while you hand off the
lectern and sit back down.
When you take a moment to picture what
it is that you want, that becomes your
reality.
And of course,
relax.
How do you relax?
For me,
I like to breathe.
I like to do 4-second inhale,
and then a 4-second exhale. If you're
all willing, if you could practice it
with me.
Inhale for 4 seconds through your nose.
Out through your mouth.
>> [sighs]
>> Just doing it once
already helps me feel a little bit of
relief from the nerves that I'm feeling
today from doing this speech.
Now, when I'm up here, I cut it in half.
I do a quick 2-second
before I begin.
And then this one's my favorite, the
movement part.
Our bodies hold so much stress. You need
to move to let it out.
If you are all willing, if you could
stand up to do my favorite exercise
before I do a speech,
shake your right arm,
shake your left arm,
roll your wrists,
tilt your head,
shake your left arm leg,
>> [laughter]
>> shake your right leg,
and now you shake it all out, and you
just let it release.
That's my favorite. Thank you. You can
all sit now. I appreciate you
participating.
That's my favorite because it helps me
feel energized, and my nerves are out.
I'm not shaking anymore. I feel
fantastic.
In conclusion,
nerves before speaking, normal.
It's what we do with it.
Do we let it overtake us?
Do we walk up confidently? When you do
that, people aren't going to notice your
sweaty palms.
You just need to remember
in those moments
of anxiousness and anxiety,
that a little bit of adrenaline's good
because it's going to help your speaking
be energetic.
But you need to practice.
You need to visualize.
Breathe.
Move.
Get up here and speak anyway.
>> What a great speech by Samantha. Okay,
it's time to see my evaluation, how I
evaluated the speech at the same club
meeting. Remember, if you're giving a
speech evaluation, it should be between
2 and 3 minutes. I barely came before
the red light at 2 minutes 58 seconds.
Here is my evaluation of Samantha's
speech.
>> Thank you, Mr. Toastmaster, fellow
Toastmasters, and Elka joining us on
Teams.
Today, Samantha taught us how to be
tenacious in overcoming speaking
anxiety, and who better to learn from
than an award-winning Toastmaster of our
own.
What Samantha did right off the start
was a great intro. She brought us into
our speech. There's a few ways you can
catch the audience's attention with an
intro. The first is asking a
thought-provoking question. You can give
a powerful statistic, or you can jump
right into a story. And what Samantha
chose to do is asking the audience to
participate. So, sort of a question, she
said, "I want you to think of a time
where you dealt with speaking anxiety,
or that you felt anxious."
So, as an audience, we were immersed in
the idea right away.
The next thing Samantha did really well
was her pacing and pausing throughout
the speech. An example of this is when
she asked the question, "How do you
relax?"
You breathe.
And then she walked us through the
breathing exercise where we could
practice that as well, giving us more
tips to overcome this in the future.
My favorite thing Samantha did
throughout the speech was body language.
And Samantha is always good at using the
full stage when she speaks, but she got
the whole audience participating in body
language today. We stood up, we shook
out our hands, we shook out our feet.
And
for myself, I felt more relaxed right
there.
All of these examples were showing that
Samantha is an expert in what she is
talking about, which makes it more valid
for the audience.
So, how can Samantha make the speech
even better in the future? There's two
things that come to mind. The first is
that Samantha used a PowerPoint or
visual aids, and in this room,
typically, our PowerPoints are limited
to a small screen. My challenge for
Samantha in the future, use fewer words
on the slides and make them as big as
possible. I'm talking 100-point text.
Have that as just the word, because we
don't need to read what is on the
screen. We just need one word that is
going to clue us in in the future.
The next thing Samantha could improve
upon is starting off with more powerful
vocal variety. It got there. Later in
the speech, she talked about the
contest, "Samantha Hildebrand!" and her
feeling that anxiety.
But initially, it was a little bit
quiet, a little bit hard to hear.
So, Samantha continues to have those
powerful intros, use the body language,
control her pacing, and then just work
on the slides, and also have that
ability to use vocal variety from the
start, she's going to continue to take
her speeches to the next level. I hope
you got value from that live evaluation.
And now for perhaps the best part,
how did I structure that? What was I
doing when Samantha was speaking in
order to prepare my brain and know that
I could deliver her with value with an
evaluation?
I do like to write notes when I give an
evaluation, and my writing is probably
very difficult to read, but there's a
couple things that are important. One, I
always like to put the word of the day
near the top of my piece of paper.
And so you may be able to read it. It
was tenacity for that meeting. So I
always put that near the top and I have
a little box around it. And that's a
reminder when I glance at my page and I
see that, it's a reminder to try to use
the word of the day and try to sneak it
in early if I can.
How I like to do this is on my piece of
paper, I have two sections. One is a
plus
and one is a minus section. And so I
create that before I even add any text
or write any words down. I have the plus
and the minus. And the plus is things
that I think the speaker did very well
and the minus is the areas that I think
that they could improve upon in the
future.
So I've already got my page layout set
up before Samantha even starts to speak.
And as she's speaking, I start to make
notes in both of those areas. Things
that I notice. So for me, body language
was really obvious because Samantha's
good at moving around the room, but also
she had this incorporation where she got
everyone to stand up and participate in
body language. So that was a no-brainer
for me. Right away, I had body language
up in the top. And then I noticed when
she came out, as I mentioned in my
evaluation,
her voice was a little bit softer than
I'm used to Samantha being. Usually she
comes out with more enthusiasm and
energy. And so right away I could write
vocal variety under the minus section
and I knew that that was something that
I could suggest for an improvement.
Now once I start to categorize those
different things, and by the way, every
speech, no matter who's speaking,
there's common things that will probably
fall into one of these buckets. Things
like eye contact, body language, vocal
variety, speech structure,
humor, use of humor. These are all
things that every good speech has these
elements. And so, you already know the
puzzle pieces, and so it's just a matter
of connecting the dots. Did the speaker
do those things well, or where could
they have improved upon? And here's the
real key. The real secret to all of this
is trying to find specific examples
that you can then reference.
And I want you to listen very carefully
in the first few words that the speaker
gives. Because whatever intro the
speaker starts with, that's often they
do a good job or they do
an intro that could be improved upon.
And so, by writing that down, you're
going to remember. Otherwise, if you try
to remember 20 seconds into the speech
how they started the speech, your brain
might have already forgotten what they
said specifically. So, have your pen
ready to write down that first line, and
then that way you can kind of judge was
that really well done, or is that
something that could be improved upon?
Because the intro is so important.
So, then you just try to find your
specific examples. So, in the speech
evaluation I gave, I talk about the
power of pausing.
And how Samantha did that really well.
And the specific example I used is how
do you relax?
You breathe.
And so, when you write down these
specific examples, now when you're
giving the evaluation, you can look at
the crowd, you can make eye contact, and
it's just a quick glance down to see
your notes, so that you're not standing
there reading everything off of a piece
of paper. It's just that quick glance,
and then you can address the audience
once again.
This is an important tip for anyone who
is in a speech evaluation contest.
Are those still happening, by the way?
Our club didn't have one of those the
last year. Somebody let me know in the
comments. I don't know if the evaluation
contest are still happening or maybe
that was just our club that didn't have
it.
But if you are in a speech evaluation
contest,
you want to summarize at the end.
I did that in this evaluation. I said,
"So, if Samantha continues to use great
body language, powerful intro,
pacing and pausing, but also adjust her
slides in the future and incorporates
vocal variety right off the start, she
is going to continue to elevate her
speeches."
That summary is a whole section on the
judges' sheets in the contest.
You definitely want to ensure that you
are
adding that. Because if you don't, the
judges will be forced to give you a
zero, and that's I think it's five
points that's against you automatically
for not having the conclusion. Maybe
it's 10 points. I'm just going off the
top of my head, but include that if you
are in a contest. Now, I think these
skills are beneficial, evaluating,
listening carefully, whether we're
talking about Toastmasters or not. I
think the ability to really understand
what makes a great speech and be able to
give people constructive feedback after
their speeches and help them become
better communicators is really powerful,
as well.
A couple things I want to draw your
attention to. If you ever want me to
personally
evaluate one of your speeches, there is
an option on my Stand Store. The links
are all under the video for this.
That you can you can sign up for that.
It's a one-time cost. You send me the
video, and I will give you a custom
video example. It's not It's me. It's
not somebody else else. I don't
outsource this. It is me watching your
video, taking notes just like I did for
Samantha's speech, and then giving you
video feedback on your speech. So, if
you think that that could be beneficial
for a speech that's really important to
you, take me up on that.
If you are planning on competing in a
Toastmasters speech evaluation contest
anytime in the future, check out this
video that's popping up because this is
where I deep dive specifically into how
to do a contest speech evaluation,
getting into the nitty-gritty. And as
always, please consider subscribing to
my channel and check out that Stand
Store link cuz I offer all sorts of
services to help you be a more
professional
eloquent communicator. Thank you for
watching this video. I'll catch you on
the next one.